son frutos de indignación es sentimiento
los movimientos populares son un
sentimiento de injusticia en un proceso
electoral las manifestaciones pacíficas
siempre serán bienvenidas
pero a nuestros métodos no pueden ser
los de la izquierda
que siempre provocaron a la población
como la destrucción del patrimonio
los derechos surgieron de verdad en
nuestro país
nuestra robusta representación en el
congreso Nuestra fuerza de los valores
Dios padre familia y verdad
formamos diversas liderazgos en Brasil
y están más vivos que nunca
somos por la orden y el progreso
Asimismo enfrentando cualquier sistema
superamos una pandemia y las
consecuencias de una guerra
por otro lado siempre fui
llamado como un demócrata en contra de
lo que decían mis acosadores
manteniendo las líneas de la
Constitución
nunca hablé de la censura de las redes
sociales y los medios de comunicación
como el presidente de la república es un
ciudadano continuaré cumpliendo todos
los mandatos de la constitución
soy ahora el líder de millones de
brasileños que como ahora defiendo la
libertad religiosa la libertad de
opinión la honestidad
y los colores del verde y amarillo de
nuestra bandera Muchas gracias